one of the things that we have a
difficulty and a confusion at the moment
is just how in law are we defining the
category of woman what what does sex
mean in law that's become really really
complicated and really really contested
lately but one thing that was clear in
the law up until this bill was coming in
was that it was not on the basis of self
ID you couldn't just declare yourself to
be a member of the opposite sex and then
legally be treated as a member of the
opposite sex what you did have in law
were protections for people on the basis
of what's referred to as gender
reassignment you're protected in
discrimination law so you can't be fired
for this which of course feminists have
always supported we shouldn't
discriminate against people because of
the way they live their lives in the
sense that they live as the opposite sex
it started to get very difficult didn't
it when transactivity started to say we
are women we are female we will enter
the spaces and we don't agree with
exemptions